My first introduction to Hillsdale College
was my high school literature teacher brought
us to a play here on campus.
My step-grandmother, who attended Hillsdale
College many, many years ago, encouraged me
to apply for a job here at Hillsdale.
So I did, and I started on September 3rd,
1968, and I started in the admissions department.
I worked for Hillsdale College almost 46 years.
I have worked for five athletic directors.
Each one of them have impacted my life.
To work for these great men has just been
wonderful, and the student athletes ... It's
been so rewarding to watch them grow in their
skill of sport as well as mature into fine
men and women.
It's so much fun.
I've kept contact with many coaches and student
athletes, and it's just really been wonderful.
I don't think I should say a favorite sport.
I suppose basketball is my favorite, but that
might have to do with the weather a bit as
well.
The whole athletic department is like a family,
and I have to say the entire college is, too.
When there was a need, everyone would pitch
in and work together.
Everyone cares about each other.
The three most important things in my life:
Faith, my family, and my Charger Family.
To be inducted into the Hall of Fame, I still
can't quite believe it's happening.
I received the letter in the mail.
It said, "Congratulations.
You are being inducted," and of course, I
had mailed out that letter for many years
to people.
I looked at it and I put it down, and I looked
at it again, and I thought, "I just can't
believe this."
I'm honored, I'm humbled, I'm astounded.
It's just wonderful.